a
[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález si miramos el
continente africano la atención está
concentrada en esa tensión que tiene
lugar en etiopía vemos a un grupo
rebelde el frente de liberación popular
de tigre que ha acumulado fuerza a nivel
territorial vemos también a un gobierno
federal que está dispuesto a todo hasta
realizar arrestos arbitrarios para
defender la soberanía y a la ciudadanía
de ese país vemos también a la población
civil en medio del fuego cruzado cerca
de 1000 personas han fallecido en estas
confrontaciones desde noviembre del 2020
también están expuestos a las hambrunas
a las detenciones y a la falta de
oportunidades a esto hay que añadir una
economía que no consigue despegar en
todas las zonas rurales también la
pandemia del cobi 19 las crisis de los
países vecinos como por ejemplo sudán
ciudad del sur la atención que hay con
eritrea y el conflicto que hay en
somalia en donde hay presencia de grupos
yihadistas todos estos ingredientes son
los ingredientes perfectos no solo para
desestabilizar a un país como etiopía de
más de 100 millones de habitantes sino
también a la región del cuerno de áfrica
o áfrica occidental así es como están
las cosas veamos
tensión máxima en las calles de la
capital etíope en la región de tigre
miles de personas fueron arrestadas
arbitrariamente desde la semana pasada
incluyendo miembros del personal de las
naciones unidas-
sexting nació los 16 funcionarios
nacionales fueron detenidos mientras que
6 fueron liberados por supuesto estamos
trabajando activamente con el gobierno
de etiopía para asegurar su liberación
inmediata lewis las detenciones se
producen tras la declaración la semana
pasada de un estado de emergencia
previsto para seis meses después de que
las fuerzas leales al frente de
liberación popular de tigre reinvindicar
han importantes avances en el norte de
etiopía lo que levantó alertas de una
posible invasión a la capital las
medidas de emergencia permiten al
gobierno detener sin orden judicial a
cualquier persona sospechosa de
colaborar con un grupo terrorista la
comisión de derechos humanos de etiopía
declaró que está supervisando un aumento
de los arrestos de tigray anos en addis
abeba el departamento de estado de eeuu
y washington encuentra los informes
preocupantes
winners
entendemos por los informes que los
detenidos son tigray anos el acoso y la
detención por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad del gobierno etíope por
motivos étnicos son completamente
inaceptables es cumplir y axa las
tensiones entre el gobierno etíope y la
onu se ha elevaron desde que estalló la
guerra en tigre el pasado noviembre en
septiembre el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores expulsó a siete altos
funcionarios de la onu acusando los de
entrometerse en los asuntos del país
sólo unos días después de que la onu
advirtiera que el bloque humanitario de
la región ponía a cientos de miles de
personas en riesgo de hambruna
la capital etíope la ciudad de addis
abeba es una de las capitales africanas
más dinámicas del continente es el
centro económico político y académico de
ese país es también la sede de la unión
africana y es el principal hub de
conexiones aéreas en el continente
africano
addis está bajo amenaza por parte de los
grupos rebeldes incluso el gobierno
llamó a los ciudadanos a defender la
capital de ser necesario los ciudadanos
por supuesto respaldaron la medida
en apoyo al ejército y al gobierno
etíope miles de personas salieron a las
calles de la capital addis abeba para
circular a las fuerzas oficiales
rechazar la alianza de fuerzas rebeldes
de tigre que amenazan con avanzar hacia
la ciudad
marchemos al frente debemos tomar la
decisión ahora de luchar por la
independencia de nuestro país tenemos
que garantizar la paz de nuestra ciudad
tenemos que bloquear la vía de entrada y
salida a las fuerzas de distracción y
sofocar los
desde hace cinco días el país está en
estado de emergencia debido a la
intensificación del conflicto en la
norteña región de tigre que ya entró en
su primer año y deja miles de muertos y
más de dos millones de desplazados
internos los manifestantes portaban
enormes pancartas con eslóganes que
criticaban la cobertura de los medios de
comunicación occidentales sobre etiopía
otros mostraron su enfado por el
llamamiento de washington para que el
gobierno federal y el frente de
liberación popular de tigre inicien
conversaciones
de no más negociación porque el gobierno
de eeuu no negocia con terroristas como
al shabab quieren destruir nuestro país
como hicieron en afganistán nunca lo
conseguirán nada
la razón por la que estoy aquí hoy es en
primer lugar para ganancia la invasión
de la enemiga en mi país en segundo
lugar para venirme al ejército
el sábado el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas emitió un comunicado
respaldado por 15 países en el que
responsabiliza de graves crímenes y
abusos de derechos humanos a todas las
partes que luchan en el conflicto etíope
pues como ustedes ya lo ven es
preocupante la situación en etiopía y la
pregunta que muchos sectores se hacen es
si este país está rumbo a una guerra
civil también que puede hacer la
comunidad internacional qué papel puede
jugar la unión africana y qué tanta
presión hay sobre el primer ministro
etíope había med quien fue galardonado
con el premio nobel de paz por ese
acuerdo de paz que alcanzó con la vecina
eritrea un país ubicado al norte de las
fronteras de etiopía pues este es
nuestro tema de debate hoy aquí en
france24 y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a la doctora hilda varela
barraza ella es docente de relaciones
internacionales y ciencia política es
también experta en historia y procesos
políticos sociales de la áfrica
subsahariana
ella se encuentra en la ciudad de mexico
y también está con nosotros manuel
inglés él es profesor de la sociedad de
estudios internacionales es experto en
historia de el continente africano
también de temas relacionados con el
islam y con temas relacionados con el
norte de áfrica y medio oriente se
encuentra en la ciudad de madrid en
españa
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
hacen parte de esta conversación de este
análisis de este debate a través de sus
preguntas y comentarios que los pueden
dejar en las redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos como arroba france24 guión bajo
es sant y luego mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios
comienzo entonces con la doctora il de
la ciudad de mexico allí la capital de
la república mexicana comienzo doctora
hilda haciéndole la pregunta con la que
titulamos este programa etiopía hasta el
borde de una guerra civil
bueno en la práctica ya se habla de una
guerra civil no estaríamos al borde
lamentablemente sino que ya estaría
habría una guerra civil porque el grupo
del norte los tigres ians avanzan todo
y están cada vez más cerca de la capital
eso ya implica que efectivamente ya hay
una guerra civil lamentablemente
y señor manuel que es en la ciudad de
madrid en españa le hago la misma
pregunta esta etiopía entonces al borde
de una guerra civil ya está en una
guerra civil tomando un poco las
palabras que dice la doctora hilda
buenas noches o buenos días desde madrid
pues estoy totalmente de acuerdo con la
doctora hilda ya se encuentra en una
guerra civil y desgraciadamente con el
número de víctimas que superan ya las
mil personas número de desplazados con
más de cien mil doscientos mil según la
cifra que se puedan barajar y hasta un
millón o dos millones también según las
cifras de personas que se cuenta los
desplazados refugiadas con lo cual la
situación es bastante alarmante y como
ha dicho los básicos para una guerra en
este caso entonces manuel y doctora
hilda les pregunto cómo es que la
comunidad internacional no le alertó
desde un principio la situación o porque
no hubo
alarmas tempranas en torno a lo que
estaba pasando en etiopía y ya se llegó
a este escenario no fue posible evitar
esta confrontación este conflicto esta
guerra civil que piensa usted manuel
bueno los conflictos a veces pueden
interpretarse son complicados en este
caso de etiopía que es un país complejo
complejo en sus raíces está tónicas
complejos son raíces étnicas incluso
religiosos alguna patria ligera en este
conflicto se ha quedado poquito al
segundo plano la parte técnica es muy
importante tengamos en cuenta que
estamos en un país es con más de 80
etnias y unas 114 suspendidas de la cual
la más importante es la de los aromas la
del presidente actual a bit que son unos
40 miles de personas tratando de un
precinto 15 miles de personas complicado
en su esencia y además
complicado con los vecinos vemos que las
tensiones que han ido creciendo con los
vecinos aunque se lleve bien con somalia
porque les ayudó con el tema yihadista
el presidente actual sin embargo la
relación con los vecinos del norte tanto
sudan como egipto está siendo un poco
tensa después de la construcción de la
de esta gran empresa que ha hecho
etiopía y que puede dañar la economía
tanto sudanesa como la economía egipcia
esto provoca también tensiones por
cuanto esto empieza a complicar
situación y además esta empresa está
cofinanciada en un 30 por ciento por
pero también complica más todavía los
factores china que tiene su primera base
marítima justamente en yibutí el país
vecino son factores geopolíticos que van
a hacer mucho más complejo el asunto de
etiopía y en la parte interna en
concreto no solamente porque esta
minoría de los tigris que bueno una
minoría que son casi 8 millones de
personas
se están juntando con partes de la línea
que son del presidente con lo cual
grupos de bromas que están juntándose
también en la acción contra el
presidente está claro que lo que vemos
que el asunto se está complicando cada
día sobre todo que está muy cerca de
la realidad etíope es una realidad muy
ajena a américa latina por eso hemos
traído este tema al debate de france 24
para explicar lo que está sucediendo
allí en manuel menciona 80 etnias
diferentes un país de 115 millones de
habitantes es el segundo más poblado de
áfrica doctora hilda como han convivido
a lo largo de los años estas 80 etnias
en este país tan diverso y tan
complicado tal parece para unificar pero
que a la vez tiene una historia
como estado muy interesante nunca fue
colonizado y se ha mantenido en cierta
unidad para enfrentar amenazas externas
sí bueno la historia es sumamente
completa es importante tomar en cuenta
que realmente lo que actualmente
conocemos como etiopía es producto de
conquistas que empezaron en principio
desde mediados del siglo xiv 90 las
conquistas y sobre todo se
intensificaron a partir de finales del
siglo 19 entonces eso provocó que
obviamente haya muchas rencillas entre
los distintos
grupos técnicos y aquí subrayado que
políticos generalmente están en juego
tanto una lucha por el poder por una
representación en el gobierno federal y
por otro lado en varias ocasiones casos
de tigray es muy notorio está también el
problema de la tierra entonces bueno la
historia realmente de etiopía ha sido
una historia de conflictos de continuas
cultades y recordemos que durante mucho
tiempo estuvo en el poder un gobierno
que se decía oficialmente de izquierda
yo lo particular creo que que nunca fue
la izquierda era solamente el discurso
político que atraía en un momento dado
hasta que el 91 fue derrocado ahora
cuando fue derrocado jugó un papel muy
importante
precisamente el frente de liberación del
pueblo es de tigray el que está
actualmente en conflicto con el gobierno
federal y el actual primer ministro
abhisit él era miembro de ese grupo que
participó en el derrocamiento del
gobierno
de corte supuestamente
de izquierdas digamos no entonces bueno
las relaciones subrayó son político
económicas muy conflictivas en toda la
región hay muchas causas históricas para
que en un momento dado haya fracturas
hay muchas muchas rencillas en el caso
de lo que ahorita está pasando
indudable que se veía venir este
conflicto por lo menos desde 2018 cuando
tomó el poder a villa ya era muy notable
la ruptura entre el frente para el
frente nacional de liberación del pueblo
y tigray y el propio gobierno federal
entonces ya desde ahí se podría haber
evitado este rompimiento yo creo que
aquí un aspecto que es fundamental es
que hay una lucha local tigray empezó
por una reivindicación de una mayor
representación en el gobierno federal y
obviamente de ahí se fue allá fue
avanzando en sus reclamos lógica lo que
piden es la destitución del gobierno
apto para la formación de un gobierno de
transición
manuel importante profundizar en este
grupo rebelde de liberación de esta
provincia de este estado del norte de
etiopía tigre que justamente tiene
frontera con eritrea un país con el que
también hay una historia de conflicto y
que a lo largo de estos últimos años han
tratado de estrechar los lazos entre
addis abeba y asmara
pero tal parece que la relación sigue un
poco congelada o al menos así lo ve la
comunidad internacional vámonos a la
región de tigre manuel quiénes son estos
rebeldes profundicemos en lo que piden y
en qué condiciones está este estado
porque piden reivindicaciones quiénes
son
en este grupo primero que es tigre
responde al nombre del entorno físico
pero también al nombre de la etnia
preponderante el estado no la única pero
sea preponderante
ellos han sido protagonistas del cambio
de gobierno con lo cual tres y siete
protagonistas de esta modificación en
las políticas de etiopía aparte de que
en el año 93 allá de creador y pre y ya
por fin año 2002 tras una guerra con
etiopía la onu por fin consigue aplacar
un poquito los ánimos y se consigue ya
la independencia y entre de fronteras
delimitadas fronteras entre tour y crear
la relación por supuesto seguir estando
ahí por si este resquicio de lo que fue
una guerra en crea y etiopía con
respecto al grupo de los tigres pues el
dirigente además precisamente es el que
ha estado en las elecciones últimas del
año
2020 que no se celebraron que es una de
las causas por la que se produce el
conflicto las elecciones tanto graf al
2020 pero por causa del hobbit el
presidente de primer ministro adel de
sirio prorrogarlas esto qué es lo que
dio pie pues a que el tigre
y si se superan las elecciones o
pretendes hacerlas y estoy provocó la
tensión entre el gobierno central y el
gobierno de haití great el primer paso
que se dio no se sabe muy claramente si
fue un ataque a una base federal por
parte de los tigres o directamente del
ejército nacional
etíope atacó a los tigres de cualquier
manera se inició el conflicto en avión
el año pasado y desde ese momento este
año pues ha continuado en crescendo de
más todo el conflicto y lo como está
diciendo antes es uno de los candidatos
para la presidencia por si va a ser el
dirigente de tira y como podemos también
se junta el tema de alcanzar el poder
personal y además el athletic pretende
acaparar un poquito más de poder por
parte de la etnia decoración dice manuel
continuó con usted para hacerle una
pregunta quiero compartir uno de los
análisis que leía preparando el
contenido para este programa algunos
analistas hablan de una posible
balcanización de etiopía que este país
como estado como lo conocemos se
desintegre y dé paso a otra serie de
países más pequeños como ya sucedió con
eritrea que era de etiopía y pasó a ser
un estado independiente y de hecho
etiopía perdió toda la costa en el mar
rojo al perder este territorio puede
suceder esto como lo ven ustedes es
factible una balcanización una
desintegración como lo ven
pues sí luego los trazos son los
siguientes tengamos en cuenta que hay
diez regiones y dos ciudades especiales
en etiopía cada región responde
prácticamente a una etnia principal soto
las cinco primeras regiones son en diez
principales
pero solamente en el mundo hay dos
países que reconocen
el derecho autodeterminación de los
pueblos como son christian stein y
etiopía precisamente ante esta respuesta
y desde que está gobernando el actual
primer ministro se han solicitado por
parte de diez etnias más el crear
regiones tengamos en cuenta que la
décima región se creó hace muy poquito
si esto continúa así decir si
conseguimos con la legalidad que tiene
el país que estas etnias reivindiquen su
autonomía
y se les conceda igual que será
concedido para hace muy poquito
tendríamos otros 10 estados más tenemos
como 20 estados doblaremos el número de
provincias o demarcaciones que hay en
en etiopía esto por supuesto es una
marca nización entonces ya estaba
organizado el país en la parte étnico
religiosa pero ahora sería también una
bancarización en sentido de la división
territorial del mismo
hilda como ve usted el papel de la
comunidad internacional
los socios occidentales
apostaban por esta reforma esta
transición que estaba viviendo el país a
nivel político también una pacificación
precisamente el primer ministro se ganó
el premio nobel de paz por haber logrado
ese acuerdo de paz con eritrea el país
estaba tomando un rumbo que a los países
occidentales le agradaba digámoslo así
pero tal parece que la comunidad
occidental
fracasó en estos intentos o en esta
percepción y el país pues está rumbo a
un conflicto y muchos temen que se
repita algo como afganistán donde el
mundo occidental se fue los dejo a su
suerte y cualquier cosa puede pasar allí
bueno ahorita que pareciera que los
rebeldes y aquí habría que subrayar que
no solamente ya son los tigre ians sino
que están unidos al ejército de oromo
del pueblo por plomo entonces bueno
conforme los rebeldes se están avanzando
y existe la alta posibilidad de que
lleguen a la capital pareciera que se
han intensificado las presiones
internacionales tanto en el gobierno
federal como en los rebeldes de tigray
precisamente para que haya una
negociación por otro lado hay un
debilitamiento
obviamente etiopía ha sufrido todos los
efectos de la cob y tránsitos de
elementos hay un deterioro económico muy
importante en la prosperidad que tenía
hace dos o tres años de etiopía entonces
obviamente está este conflicto está
haciendo mella en la situación de
etiopía por otro lado también los
rebeldes por un lado enfrenta por lo
menos 400 mil pesos riesgo de muerte por
falta de alimentos están
del norte es limpia y hay conflictos
territoriales
históricos
y drive entonces obviamente por el iter
no van a recibir ningún tipo de de
abasto no hay abasto humanitario
completamente entonces eso también
podría provocar que los propios rebeldes
estén que habrá una pequeña perspectiva
para que tanto los rebeldes como el
gobierno federal lleguen a un acuerdo
por primera vez se siente en la
negociación es importante aquí recordar
que cuando empezó el conflicto el
gobierno federal decía que no tenía por
qué haber una participación
internacional una mediación
internacional para ser más correcto
porque era un asunto interno y se
trataba de un problema de aplicar la ley
audita ya las dimensiones está siendo
muy distinta a cierto alguien la pena
decir tan sólo una pequeñísima mención
que rusia ha condenado la violencia
presente distrito rusia no ha tomado
posición por ninguna de las dos partes
doctora hilda usted habla de estas
asociaciones o alianzas entre los
diferentes grupos que hay en etiopía por
ejemplo el nuevo frente unido de fuerza
federalista etíope que busca establecer
un acuerdo transicional para que el
primer ministro deje el poder y el país
pueda enrutar se lo más pronto posible
en tratar de salir adelante de la
pandemia económicamente de asistir a la
gente que está precisamente en riesgo de
hambrunas usted cree posible que el
primer ministro deje el cargo dimita a
la luz de un posible diálogo o a la
atención que se esté presentando allí
yo creo que bueno
por un lado está la fuerza armada
rebelde que sería precisamente
como y por otro lado está esta nueva
coalición que se unieron existen grupos
políticos étnicos pero no militares y
precisamente lo que quieren es que haya
un gobierno de transición en lo
particular no consciente pero que el
primer ministro sea fácilmente derrocado
o sea que fácilmente acepte retirarse
aquí tendría que ser muy fuerte de
presión internacional lo que pasa es que
también ha sido un primer ministro muy
útil entre comillas para gobiernos
occidentales entonces además es una
pieza clave en todo el estación de
áfrica entonces no creo que sea tan
fácil que haya este tipo de transición
ojalá que se llega a una mesa de
negociaciones cuando él quiera que
continuemos hablando del primer ministro
hábil lo que significa para etiopía el
peso que tiene en este momento la
atención que puede tener en este momento
y retomo lo que decía la doctora hilda
le ha sido muy útil a los países
occidentales para beneficiarse de
diferentes formas allí en este país
africano cómo ve usted la posición del
primer ministro está tal vez por el filo
del abismo cómo lo ve
bueno aquí tendríamos dos o dos formas
de verlo y amaste de acuerdo con la
doctora isla
está complicado el que se vaya ojalá que
llegue a un punto de negociación una
mesa en la que se sienten y se
soslaye el problema pero tenemos en
cuenta que las elecciones de 21 de junio
de este año de 2021 en un 90 por ciento
votaron al presidente de facsa con 420
escaños de presión 76 esto es un
refuerzo que ha tenido el muchísimo muy
grande por lo tanto su persona yo creo
que está alimentada mismo por el éxito
de estas elecciones elecciones que como
hay que tener en cuenta y dijimos antes
se han hecho este año porque no se puede
nació el año pasado por el commit y que
además en algunas zonas del país no son
poder realizar y se han ido haciendo
durante el mes de septiembre de octubre
recabando algunos votos más de cualquier
manera la aplastante mayoría que tienen
la victoria electoral del presidente
david yo creo que él ha reforzado como
persona y como líder es complicado que
con este refuerzo popular una persona
quiera dimitir pero bueno sea sos en la
geopolítica tenemos dos equipo además
que es un primer ministro que cuenta con
cierta popularidad es una persona joven
para la política etíope es carismático
era como el sinónimo del éxito que
estaba empezando a tener etiopía en
diferentes áreas y mostrándose como un
país líder de esa zona del continente
africano pero esta imagen ha empezado a
cambiar sobre todo por ese premio nobel
que le dieron y que ahora este
llamando al estado de emergencia a
defender a la capital
llamando a los capitalinos a armarse
para defender la ciudad y también por
las diferentes acusaciones que hay de
violaciones a los derechos humanos y de
tácticas no responsables por parte de
las fuerzas armadas etíope que se puede
decir sobre este tema doctora hilda
sobre estas críticas que ha hecho la onu
que ha hecho también eeuu que condenan
por los crímenes de guerra descubiertos
en investigaciones en la región de tigre
sí bueno aquí hay una cosa importante es
que hay organizaciones humanidades a
nivel internacional que denuncian que
tanto los rebeldes como el gobierno de
teherán
han cometido violaciones de los derechos
humanos aquí por ejemplo a mí una cosa
que me parece muy preocupante es que el
1er
es tu premio nobel de la paz ponga usted
atrás manualmente premio de la paz 2019
estén manejando un discurso de odio no
solamente está invitando a toda la
población civil a armarse y entré al
ejército forma voluntaria si no está
hablando de que si llegan los rebeldes a
los que denomina terroristas y llegan a
ocupar la capital
su destino va a ser que van a ser
enterrados sus huesos y su sangre es un
discurso de odio demasiado fuerte para
un país tan frágil
políticamente hablando étnicamente
hablando como el set yo diría hice todo
su discurso que uno no espera de uno
si es un discurso que no se espera de un
premio nobel de paz otorgado en el 2019
de hecho estos discursos de odio étnico
han aumentado sobre todo en las redes
sociales allí en etiopía así lo han
denunciado diferentes organizaciones
internacionales manuel continuó con
usted quiero hablar del papel de dos
importantes actores internacionales uno
la unión africana país que de hecho
tiene sede allí en addis abeba la
capital etíope y que ya empezó a ser
criticada por no actuar lo
suficientemente rápido en torno a esta
situación y también por no dar
soluciones africanas a problemas
africanos en este contexto
y ciertamente las recibieron y africanas
si ve por este caso que ha tenido una
actividad un poco pasiva no es muy
proactiva en la solución del problema de
diop y además teniendo cuenta que tiene
pie son los países que más actividad ha
tenido en las acciones militares que
tenían y africana últimamente en toda la
franja de subsahariana combatiendo el
terrorismo en somalia y compartiendo
además y aportando un montón de tropas
vivos para misiones exteriores de la
gráfica la directamente las entidades
multinacionales organizaciones
multinacionales a veces pecan de tener
poca por actividad en algunos casos no
sabemos por qué motivos y motivos y
puntos conflictivos internos o motivos
por intereses con el país en este caso
como sí se ha comentado la falta un
poquito de proactividad para un mexicano
doctora hilda decir como a la unión
africana se le critica por no haber
actuado a tiempo o no actuar rápidamente
también han criticado mucho eeuu por las
medidas que ha adoptado en frente a
etiopía
eliminar ese acceso a un lucrativo
programa comercial que tiene con eeuu un
acuerdo que tienen entre washington y
addis abeba y han criticado que eeuu ha
empezado
digamos a ahorcar un poco al gobierno
federal con esta falta de recursos
necesarios en este momento
doctora y la me oye tú
bueno creo que tenemos problemas con la
comunicación de la doctora hilda le
transfiero entonces la pregunta a manuel
mientras restablecemos la conexión con
la doctora en ciudad de mexico le
pregunto entonces manuel por el papel
que ha tenido eeuu estas medidas que ha
adoptado recientemente a washington
claro eeuu y como me vista de las
declaraciones de representante
estadunidense cuando la redacción del
presidente tú y el ministro hábil es la
de retomar la violencia confrontarse con
violencia contra los rebeldes invitar al
pueblo también a la violencia y producir
como parece seca y bones informes esta
purga interna étnico no solamente una
zona de tigre pero son las otras zonas
en la capital al salva para que todas
aquellas personas que pertenezcan a la
línea y grace sean eliminadas del su
puesto de trabajo sean de gran manera
llevadas al ostracismo esto ha llevado a
eeuu a estas declaraciones en las cuales
es bueno estar ahora mismo invitando a
que a que la situación se calme pero eso
también provoca como ha ocurrido otras
veces en otros estados que la población
pues se revele contra cualquier tipo de
intervención externa bueno creo que
hemos retomado la comunicación con la
doctora hilda y en ciudad de méxico
doctora aída queremos conocer su opinión
sobre la pregunta que le hacía sobre el
papel de eeuu adelante
bueno cuando empezó el conflicto los
llamados a llegar a una mesa de acuerdos
eran muy suaves eran muy ligeros pero
ahorita que existe la posibilidad de que
los rebeldes lleguen en la capital se ha
intensificado la relación de toda la
presión para que negocien tanto rebeldes
como el gobierno de estados pero el
gobierno federal como los rebeldes
entonces ahorita hay una situación un
tanto desesperada porque se teme que si
llegan a tomar los rebeldes la capital
va a ser una situación sumamente difícil
y va a ser absolutamente incontrolable
pero también otra cosa importante hay
otros países que también son muy
importantes para etiopía y que desde el
inicio han pedido la negociación ccoo
que trata realmente el gobierno de
francia incluso el presidente francés se
ofreció a el servir como mediador para
que hubiese un acuerdo de paz pero sin
embargo las presiones nunca fueron
fuertes porque no se quería
desestabilizar al gobierno del primer
ministro se aprovechó que tenemos buena
conexión con usted doctora hilda para
que nos dé sus conclusiones ya estamos
en la parte final del
qué va a suceder siempre digo no tenemos
la bola de cristal para saber el futuro
de este tipo de conflictos y situaciones
pero usted que cree que va a suceder en
este país en los próximos meses
bueno en primer lugar yo creo que habría
que subrayar que actualmente está
considerado como uno de los conflictos
más sangrientos a nivel mundial y
generalmente hay muy poca atención a lo
que pasa en áfrica y este es un caso muy
simplificado ahora en cuanto a la salida
efectivamente ojalá pudiéramos predecir
una salida exitosa vía negociación para
mí es indudable que la solución militar
no tiene ningún futuro y lo único que
provocaría sería mayor sangre mayor
sufrimiento y aquí también me permito
subrayar que hay que distinguir entre la
élite incluso tigra jan y la población
civil que es la que realmente está
sufriendo entonces yo espero que haya
una capacidad de ambos bandos para
llegar a una negociación y se ponga fin
en forma pacífica al conflicto al menos
directa moss a mediano plazo
lamentablemente hay raíces muy fuertes
que pueden provocar que otra vez el
conflicto vuelve a estallar
las opiniones de la doctora hilda varela
en la ciudad de mexico y para el cierre
le pregunto a manuel inglés en madrid su
conclusión sobre este tema
la conclusión es que es muy decisivo lo
que se produce estos días porque estamos
en un punto de casi no retorno en el
punto este de la capital está a punto de
caer por partes rebeldes llegamos a este
punto de no retorno por la propia
definición sería un conflicto
irremediable y además con muchísimas
víctimas por lo tanto me uno a la
opinión de la doctora lynda en que
esperemos que sean lo suficientemente
cautos para sentarse todos a negociar y
no lleguen a cruzar este umbral ya de
violencia total y nos mantengamos el
streak que por lo menos se retorne a un
cauce de paz
bueno pues son las opiniones de nuestros
invitados aquí en el debate france24
nuestro tema de hoy era la crisis que se
está viviendo en etiopía un país
africano que está al borde de entrar a
una guerra civil a algunos de nuestros
analistas ya dijeron que de hecho el
país se encuentra ya en una guerra civil
eran las opiniones de algunos de ellos
ustedes pueden también seguir dejando
sus opiniones y preguntas a través de
las redes sociales del canal de france
24 y pueden seguir dejando allí todos
sus comentarios a mis invitados les
agradezco por habernos acompañado ya
ustedes muchas gracias por lass y sigan
con france24
[Música]